uh so welcome everyone um
i hope you're having a great day
and i'm going to be talking about
asp.net core
and i'm calling it beyond the
introduction because
i want to show you some of the things
that they don't show you in the let's
get started with asp.net core sessions
uh there's gonna be a little bit of high
and a little bit of low stuff there's
gonna be some things that you might have
seen before and i can pretty much
guarantee you i will show you something
you have never seen in a core
at the end of the session so
let's just see what we can do
my name is
my name is chris klogg i work for a
company called active solution in
stockholm
i go around the world talking at
conferences when i'm not paid to do
software development development and
architecturing um for different
companies so i have a consultancy
background
also i've got some
mvp stuffy thingies i've i've seen
asp.net core being developed internally
a little bit more than most people which
is interesting
but that's all the slides i have for you
so i'm going to try for about 59 minutes
code in front of you live on a stage
built for a tiny oompa loompa
but
i'll do my best i can't see anything
because of the lights and i can't see my
keyboard because i have to stand like
this but i'll do my best sorry about
that
but hopefully there are no other
technical issues so i've built this
website it is beautiful it shows off my
talent as a designer
once upon a time i was firstly an art
director i went into coding
so what i've got in here is a little
website you can click on view details so
you can come in you can see information
about hidden lamar um
so one of the things i don't like about
this website it's a it's a plain old
aspect that the asp.net core website
standard nothing changed impressive at
all and one thing i don't like about
this is my urls up here right so i don't
know if you see it in the back but it
says slash users one
not the greatest urls if you want to do
search engine optimization not the
greatest url in general it's just not
great so i want to fix that
and i want to do that using something
that
some of you might have seen some of you
haven't because a lot of people get
started with a core and they they look
at the startup thing and it's like yeah
in this configure method here we call
can the people in the back say that by
the way
i can increase the fund a bit
so how how old are you
let's see if i can find a
con apparently couldn't couldn't do plus
let's do is is that old enough
sweet
i'm just kidding obviously i'm probably
older than you
so mostly you go in here you go that
configure thing you call app dot and
then use something something and then
magic happens most people don't think
too much about what happens inside here
but it's actually a pretty cool pipeline
in here where we can go in and do things
on our own so we could for example go in
here when wanting to fix the thing that
i want to fix
and add a little i've got some snippets
here because i don't want to code in
front of you
so i'm just going to pull in and
i have an injection of eye users
repository
like that
so the configure method is is fully
dependency injectable so that's fine so
what i do here is that i do an app use
and i give it a a callback
and that's basically an inline thing
that's going to run
after it it looks for static files but
before it does request routing and all
i'm doing in here is i go in and i look
at the path and i take the path making
sure that it's longer than just one
which is slash making sure that
it's not more than one flash so it's
basically something that's it and then
if that's the case i look into the
user's repo figuring out if there's a
user with that name based on the path so
that path remove the dash with the space
instead
if i find the user
i actually change and this is the
important part here
context.request.path equals so the http
context in aspect core is read write
it's not read only like it used to be so
we can go ahead and change it
so i can actually go in i can change the
path to slash user slash user id so if i
go and do slash heady dash lamar
up until that middleware is going to be
slash headlamar but after that it's
going to be slash user slash one and
then it just carries on with await next
and then on the way back out again i'm
changing the path back if there's any
other pipeline thing before me that
wants the the original path
with that in place
we should be able to
we should be able to hear this
go heady lamar
and i get to this instead so i've got
now the ability to do changes to my urls
and it's the actual functionality of url
rewrites not very important it's
actually quite performance intensive to
do what i'm doing so resource intensive
might not be useful but i wanted to show
this idea that we can plug into the
pipeline in these really rudimentary
low-level ways and do stuff that we
couldn't do before because it being read
writes
so if anybody wants to listen to event
sourcing my company has a presentation
on that right now
so but it doesn't generally look like
this right if you start writing your
middlewares like this your startup
method is going to grow and just be this
massive thousands of lines long thing
and whenever you have a method that is
thousands of lines long
you need to use regions no sorry you
need to refactor right
so what we can do here if i can
come up here and say new
add
there it is
folder there it is i'm just going to go
middlewares
and in the middlewares folder i'm going
to add a new middleware and in the
middle where it's just a class right so
i'm going to create a class in here and
i'm going to call it
name
name routing middleware
was that's that didn't spell right where
like that
so i created this class name right in
middleware and then i replace it
always work with code you have snippets
for don't take on projects where you
don't have predefined snippets just
sucks
so a middleware is just a class doesn't
need to inherit from any interface in
higher from a base class or sorry
implement any interfaces or inherit from
your base classes all it needs is a
constructor that takes a request
delegate which is a reference to the
next middleware in the pipeline and an
async or it's public task invoke a sync
method that takes an hp context that's
it
and it is fully dependence injected so
we can do our users here
and add our users
like that
after that we can go out here we can
take this piece of code here
put that in the invoke async and replace
the
next call with one that passes on the
context
once we have that we can go ahead and
change this into
use
middleware
and say name routing middleware like
that
and we're good
slightly better removes a lot of lines
of code still doesn't look quite as good
as use routing right it should just be
used name routing so
easy fix we just go create another class
i'm going to add another class in here
i'm going to call it
middleware
i can't spell middleware extensions
i'm going to blame my poor typing for
being non-native not a native english
speaker not that it matters but like
i'm gonna blame that
static making it static adding a another
little thing in here
so i'm creating this extension method
called username routing very fine what
most people do in here is they go to
this thing here and they go say hey add
using statement you're good to go don't
go up here and change this
to microsoft
dot asp.net core dot builder
and add a using statement to this thing
here instead
when you go back out here
and you go and you go
app.use
name routing that's always going to pop
up because microsoft asp.net core
builder net interface sorry namespace is
always going to be included in your
startup file because it's part of the
store file so by adding it to the same
namespace you always get when you go
app.use and everything will pop up
otherwise you need to go
namewritingmiddleware it's not there
ctrl dot include namespace blah blah
blah much easier to do like this
so that's kind of cool there's one
problem with this
that is uh it still works right so if we
can go to uh
slash
gracehopper that works what i don't like
in my application now and now i'm going
to show you something that you you you
really really really shouldn't be doing
in any way or form but i want to show it
as
you can do other things with it that
might be useful what i am specifically
doing is bad but what i've got here is
those urls can't really see it but they
still point to slash user slash one
what if i could rewrite all of those
urls
dynamically
just make them be what they should be
sweet not that hard we just go back to
our trusty old startup class we go in
here
and we say
bti we add another middleware
and this is one of those interesting
ones that people also miss is that
response.body is defined as a stream and
it's writable it has get set
so i can take the the body stream and
store that in a variable and replace it
with a memory stream
so it means that anybody down the line
from this goes body dot writes is going
to write to my memory stream nothing is
going to be returned to the user it's
going into my memory stream i've
hijacked the whole thing
sweet
with that in place
we can go and we can replace this part
with another little blog thing here and
this is ugly this is why i'm saying
don't do this because what i'm doing is
is
really really really ugly really really
poor performance but what i will show is
that it's quite easy to do
so what i do is i i replace the mem the
stream
i call the rest of the pipeline and have
the rest of the pipeline right to my
memory stream
then it comes back and i take my memory
stream and i turn it into a string i run
a regex because you obviously want to
run regex over every single thing that
comes out of your application
to make it even better you take the
respond returned regex all the places
where it finds the regex you do a for
loop of that or for each loop and then
for each one of them
actually sorry this one is a bit simpler
this this just replaced no sorry sorry
it does say users all pulls out all the
users then figures out all the users
based on whatever the regex is and and
replaces the things in the string and
then writes the string out instead
so this is this is nice because it means
that if i run this
these urls out here are now updated to
go to slash head lmr
with a massive performance hit
having that said in ashu you just pulled
this slider says more instances and
you're good to go
completely fine no so it is obviously a
performance problem so i'll fix that for
you
in another ugly fix i'm saying ugly i'm
just once again
i'm saying you shouldn't do it and
that's really i mean that but i and
people might go why is that idiot on
stage saying showing us things while
he's saying don't do this
it's because what i'm saying is don't
specifically do this because it's dumb
but the ability to replace the memory
stream or replace the stream might be
useful for other things than stupid
regular expressions and and loops inside
of it i'm just
potentially
so what i'm going to do is to to make
this a little bit better i'm going to
add a i distributed
cache in here so that i distributed
cache is an interface that's always
available in asnet core and the default
implementation is of i distributed cache
is immemory cache or sorry memory cache
which basically means it's not
distributed at all
the name is in there but it has nothing
to do with distributed it's it's an
in-memory thing in your machine but you
can replace it with something that's
distributed
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go in here
i'm going to add this
so i'm going to do and i'm going to look
into my cache to see is there anything
that's cached with this path
if there is i return that otherwise i
carry on and i let the rest of the
pipeline do its work and when it comes
back if there is an item in the hp
context item collection that's called
add to cache i'm going to cache that
byte array on coming back
and then i can go down here and in here
we can say
ctx dot
item
dot items
and not that kind of braces
like that add to cache
equals
bytes
like that
and then we can add a
add a breakpoint say there
press f5 run this
it comes in here obviously
run that again
refresh this page
and it refreshes because i now have a
cache in front of it once again stupid
stupid stupid cache but easily explains
that we can do really cool things in
line
so one of the first things i looked at
asp.net core and i was like how did they
implement that you know the use
developer exceptions thing where it
gives you an exception page that i'm
like how do they manage to do exception
handling all the way through the
pipeline and just magically catches
everything very very simple what they do
is you add a thing in here
you basically
add a a middleware and you do a try
catch around that call and in the catch
you return what you want to do and it
basically catches any exception being
done downstream
very very simple so don't get away from
don't
underestimate the abilities of doing
your own middleware so you can do a lot
of really cool stuff
um the next thing i want to show you is
around apis right because i've built
this awesome system
every awesome system needs to be api
available right so my little website
with three people in it they need an api
so i have this api here where i can run
and i might be able to assume this as
well look at that
and i can send requests to api slash
user slash one and i get hedy lamar
but
in json
and for those of you who were at hardy's
talk previously xml is the business
right we should all be doing xml instead
so to do xml i don't think that was what
he said but i'm paraphrasing
we should be able to pass in accept text
html and press send and it should come
back as
xml it doesn't it used to in asp.net
before it did in asmet core not so much
that is because they've they don't add
that ability to by default so what we
can do is we can go up here and we can
say options
and then we do options dot output
formatters dot add and i'm gonna spell
this horribly wrong in this weird
position that i am new xml serializer
output
formatter didn't come out quite right
but i
think it's going to fix it
that didn't no no no i
it did not fix it
xml serializer output format or there it
is
it's scary when you go oh yes control
dot enter it probably fixes it no no no
no no that was not the fix that i wanted
so by adding that and building this
we should be able to go out here and
send this in here and it comes back as
xml
sweet not a big thing but
i i like building apis i i build a lot
of apis it's kind of most of my work is
building apis and one thing i kind of
like is the ability to return different
types of resources and a lot of people
don't read rest and don't figure out
that except header is there for multiple
things we could have things like
with the accept header if you ever ask
for an image your browser will
automatically add an accept header
that's image star and basically says at
this resource i want you to return an
image and then the web browser will
figure out what to return
the thing here is that we can use that
to our advantage not just for images and
for html json and xml we can actually
have the endpoint return different
things in different with different
accept headers
so we can use this for versioning for
example so in my case i want to show you
this
so i'm going to go into my
controllers
api i have this very simple usage
controller here and what i want to do is
i have this user object uh which is it
does
contain a few properties right i want to
have a basic version of that i want to
have a smaller version of that that can
be returned so i don't need to get all
of that information about my user so i'm
going to go and i'm going to add another
folder in here
i'm going to go and add another folder
in here come on there it is new folder
models but chris you can't put the
models folder in the control yes i can
shut up
um then we go add new item a new class
i'm going to call it a basic user
i'm going to replace that with
that so it's just a simple class and all
it really does it filters away some of
the properties and it reduces the number
of properties to just id first name last
name
um
once i have that i'm going back to my
usage controller and down here i'm going
to go ahead and i'm going to add a
an action called get basic user
and all it really does it pulls out the
user by with with id user id and then it
it returns a basic user so it returns
less information just removing some
stuff
and you look at this and you go chris
that's not going to work and i go nope
that's very true it's not going to work
because if i run this it's going to give
me a
http 500 and it's going to say you suck
server error there are two endpoints
that can respond to slash user id
it's true and what i want to do one
thing we often do in in rest apis is we
have this idea of being able to pass in
and the standard is generally
application slash vnd dot something so
it's an application specific resource
type it's vendor based and it's a user
in this case it should probably have
been vnd.basic user but who cares i
chose that
so what i want to do is i want to take
care of that and make sure that that
thing causes this task this action to be
run not the other thing
that's easy to do which is quite fun
because all you have to do
is go ahead i went a bit too far in my
notes go ahead and add another folder in
here once again you don't need to add a
folder you can put stuff wherever you
want
but
infrastructure
straw i'm getting i'm getting too old
for this structure
that didn't come out right did it struck
whole room listening to a guy not being
able to type
sorry
class new class
ex
accept header attribute
like that replace that with an
implementation that looks like this
so i'm creating a class here called
accept header attribute inherits from
attribute so it's an attribute the does
the name and i implement i action
constraint
i action constraint defines two things
it defines a method called accept that
returns a boolean and takes an action
constraint context and it takes an order
order i don't really care about it's
it's the way that it evaluates actions
if there are multiple of them and so on
but what the accept does it says that if
it returns true it means that this
action can can run based on the context
if it returns false this action is not
valid for the current context so in here
i just go and i look at hp context
request the headers and i say is there
an accept header that starts with
whatever i passed into the constructor
okay if i take that go back to my user
controller
go in and i say accept
header
like that
so
you can remove the attribute part when
it's an attribute so you just go accept
header and you give it an acceptation
it's going to be application
slash
vnd.user like that
go back out here run this again
and we restart the server still haven't
figured out when i need to restart the
server so i'm going to do this 16 times
during the presentation it's going to
respond cannot contact server it's fine
it's just me being done so run that
always under return smaller
so i can now go ahead and say i want it
in json
i want it in xml
i want it in a smaller version
but what if i want it in a smaller
version in xml
i'm a very demanding person i know so
what we normally do in rest cases is we
do application v vnd.user plus xml so
plus whatever thing we need so xml plus
json whatever
once again we can fix this it's not even
that complicated
what we do is we go back into our
infrastructure folder we add a new class
in here the class is going to be called
i'm going to misspell this as well
accept header output
formatter
form wrapper formatter
output format so like that looks
one single typo in all of that
so the implementation for that is it's
an it inherits from output formatter
selector the output format selected in
my case is going to it has a method or
sorry it has to that it overrides a
select formatter and all it really does
it tells this the system uses it to
figure out which formatter should i use
should i how should i format this on the
way back
and i'm going to go ahead and i'm going
to add a constructor in here because i
need some
some parameters so i need the mvc
options thing which is actually if we
are
sort of picky it's it's that options you
do out here so when you configure that
options thing there that is what you're
going to get if you ever request eye
options of mvc options
then i get a logger factory
i create a default output formatter
selector as a fallback so basically
that's the one that
the people in redmond gives us it's the
default one so i'm going to use that as
a fallback if i can't figure out how to
do it then hey
you fix it
and then i'm going to have a list of
four matters that's available in the
system
and then in my select format or select
formatter i'm going to do an
implementation that looks like this
so first of all it checks to see if the
accept there is an except header that
starts with application vnd dot if not
ask the default back selector i don't
really care because i only care about
that specific for
except header
and then it checks for some formatters
and then it calls get content type from
accept header i'll explain to you what
that is and if we go in here
so what this thing does it looks at the
accept header and it gets the first
response of the accept header
and then it it looks for a plus sign
if there's a plus sign in there it takes
anything on the right hand side of the
plus character
and then it takes that value and uses
this content type map here to say if
somebody passed in that then it should
be application json if it's xml it
should be text xml
so what i do in here is i i take the
content type and i replace it with the
like the real pro content type so xml
becomes applications like
xml becomes text.xml
then i ask the formatters hey which is
the first of you that knows how to
handle this request
and then after that i reset the content
type back again to whatever it was
before i started messing about with it
so with that in place
we should be able to go to the
startup class in here and say
services.add
singleton
we want to do an output formatter
selector
there it is and i want to set accept
header
output
formatter selector
like that
we rebuild the application
go back to insomnia run this
and now i get this
short version in xml i got this short
version in json
uh and that's it
so that's kind of cool and it's this
specific implementation it's you can use
it for anything very common scenario is
versioning because this is kind of cool
because i could have application slash
vnd use vnds
application slash vnd.user
and then have maybe
user.1.0 user.1
1.1 1.2 and so on and the the client
requesting my api could if they didn't
pass it in they would get the latest
version but if they did pass it in they
could upgrade and get newer versions of
my api and i could still have the old
implementation and the new
implementation in the same code base
sweet i like that if you don't like that
you're wrong
um
i i have opinions i know
somebody's going to write that up and
give me a red note out there and i'm
going to get like a formal complaint
from the organizer sorry about that
stuff happens um
one thing i dislike about this and this
is another one of those this is fun to
do i'm not sure i would do it in the
real world but
i
don't like the fact that i'm doing two
of these right i get a user id in
and i have to go and ask reaper for it
wouldn't it be nice if i could just go
and say
user
and user and since that's now not needed
that part
it also means that my application it
doesn't need to be a sync
so all of a sudden my code looks like
this instead i actually tried this
yesterday i'm not going to do it now but
you can turn this into like a nice
little fat arrow function instead and
make it a one-liner and you don't need a
bunch of stuff but this is kind of neat
it would be nice if i could just get the
user passed in instead of the user id
right
so what we'll do here is we'll fix that
so to do that once again in my
infrastructure project i'm going to say
a folder i'm going to say new class
i'm going to create a user model binder
that didn't come out right but when i
snippet this in it's going to get fixed
anyway
so there it is
and i think if i go
rename file there is look at that look
at that okay so user model binder is a
class that implements imodelbinder
imodelbinder's only responsibility is to
bind some form of information that comes
in
from the client into some form of
something else
it has dependence injection so i pull in
my user's repo and it has this bind
model async method that we need to
implement
so i'm going to go and implement that by
saying
first of all null check for the binding
context which is completely useless
because there's always going to be one
but it's there because
safe programming
then it looks at the binding context so
binding context model metadata.name
is actually the name of the parameter
that you're trying to bind to
so when i add this this is going to be
called with the string user as the name
so i take user and i add id to the end
and then i basically go and ask what's
called the value provider say did
somebody pass in a value that was called
user id and it's going to look at the
query string and the form
if it's a form post and so on
and if it doesn't find it it just
returns
if it does find it
you you ask it for the first value if it
doesn't find the first value that would
be odd but if it doesn't it returns it
and then it tries to parse the input and
get the id if that doesn't work it adds
a model error and returns otherwise it
gets the user based on the id and it
returns a bindingresult.success
passing in the user so now i know how to
handle the binding stuff we just need
one fantastic little class more
and most people find this quite
interesting because you do a user model
binder
provider this is starting to sound like
java right
factories and providers and stuff like
that
it's not quite that bad
it's an imodel binder provider it takes
a context and it returns a binder if you
know how to bind it so in my case i look
to see are you trying to bind a user
in that case return a binder type model
binder type of user model binder what
the user or the binder type model binder
provides dependency in injection into
your model binders so you basically just
you wrap your model binder into another
model binder and magically dependence
injection works don't know why but it
does
um so now that i have that i can go back
out to my no wrong place i can go to my
startup class
we can go to the options here we can say
options
dot
use cert no
model binder providers dot and not add
because they were run in order and
there's always a default one that will
say i know how to do it and then it
fails so we do insert
insert zero
new user model binder provider
like that
we put a breakpoint in there and in
there
and we press f5 and the reason i put two
breakpoints is because i don't know
which one of them i'm going to hit
we run that it
we go back to
some insomnia we run that again it comes
in here and my user object is actually
prepared and i have that already fixed
for me
that's kind of nice
model binding is is really neat there is
a comment somewhere in the documentation
that says never ever use model binding
for things like run into the database
and fetching things which is exactly
what i showed you
so before you do this don't just take my
talk and go and do it read the docs just
a smidge and see what i was doing wrong
and don't do that
we agree with that
cool
next thing i have another application
here
so i have this application here called
let's say set a startup project
i'm showing off my magic skills when it
comes to
um application building so i've got this
application here i'm going to log in as
grace
i look like a grace
log in like that so i've got this thing
here where you manage users and they've
got john doe who's just dead weight
but they've got ad profile picture and
you want to upload a picture of of john
the problem with uploading pictures is
that it can be quite resource intensive
right so we don't want to do that as
you're uploading it i want to do that in
a background thing that runs in the
background of my application so it
doesn't bog down the thread and i don't
have to sit there and wait for it to be
resized into a thumbnail and things like
that
normally somebody doing this would say
oh you just put in hang fire just nougat
get hang fire and then go and read
massive amounts of documentation on how
to run hang fire
or you go into your application
create a new folder actually that's not
mandatory the folder is me
i'm going to add infrastructure
like that
i'm going to add a class in here
so i'm going to call it thumbnail
generator
like that
and i'm going to go ahead and make that
implement i hosted service
which is really neat it's just a very
simple interface that has start async
and stop async
so all we need to do it will tell us
when the application starts and it will
tell us when the application stops and
whatever you do in that time span is up
to you so with that in place all i need
to do is say
nope 18.
oops sorry that was my constructor that
needs to be up here
there is so i create a constructor that
takes in a hosting environment some
employees
and i'm going to create a file system
watcher
and then in my start async
i'm going to go and create this little
method here and all it really does it it
creates a folder
in my root called images or images
employees and then if it doesn't exist
it creates it and then it creates a file
system watcher and it starts listening
for files created that's it
when a file is created
it runs this bit of code
my at
20 yes i am so it runs this bit of code
here and to run that i actually need to
go and say manage nougat packages
i need to add do i have internet
connection i do so all of you who are
downloading stuff of pirate bay play
stop
uh i need six labors
image sharp there it is
install that so i don't wanna
they have a fantastic library for
modifying images
ignore the errors down there just going
to import this
import that this is the reason why you
put your extension methods in the right
namespace so you don't have to use a
specific namespace to get your extension
message to work so what it does it
basically when a file is created if it
doesn't include end with
dash thumb it's not it's it's not a
thumbnail so i need to create a
thumbnail based on the name of the file
i can figure out what tenant it is what
employee it is i can pull out the
employee
i can change my thumbnail create my
thumbnail and store the thumbnail the
cool part about this is once you haven't
hosted service you can go into your
application and just say services dot
add
hosted service
thumbnail
generator
like that
put a break point in here sort of
hereish
run the application
and every time i do this i realize that
i should have prepared a picture so when
i don't press when i press this it
doesn't open up some weird folder on my
machine
okay
i did actually put it there there's a
picture of me i do upload
it comes in here
and it asks to do the picture resize
i can't actually see the result out here
it's locked and that is only because i
this breaks all the threads at the
moment so it stops everything but if i
run this through once it's going to come
again a second time because it when it
created a file you create a thumbnail so
this this time it's actually the thumb
file
but if i go back out here i already got
the response so we can see that this was
running in the background so while i was
redoing and
creating the the thumbnails this thing
ran in the background and if i go back
out here and i refresh this the picture
is now up there
so we can do these background tasks we
got start async stop async that's and
all we need and then we can do whatever
we want in the background without
blocking up threads from the from the
foreground to run on
cool um
anybody feeling that they're slightly
out of the water yet
nope you're all so comfortable about
this level cool because now we're gonna
go down a rabbit hole of weird stuff
and this is weird stuff
okay
i sat down and i started thinking about
i use azure a lot so
in azure when you create a web
application there's a little tick box
that says add application insights you
tick that and magically you get a bunch
of logs from your application without
having added anything to your
application and i went how did they
touch my application in that way
so i had to figure this out so i'm now
going to show you
how you can build that exact feature and
inject your own functionality into any
asp.net core application that runs on a
server without the application knowing
anything about the fact that you are
injecting things into it
this is going to be awesome
so what i've got is i've got a project
here called runtime store
i don't care about runtime store the
runtime store project at all honestly it
is it has a it does have a program cs
file that looks like that
i don't care the reason i have that is
because it needs to compile for one of
my later steps what i'm interested in is
the cs proj file
so my cs project file has an item group
that defines my package references so
what nougat packages am i dependent on
that's the important part and i've also
updated the the nougat endpoints to use
nougat and also sort of the request
diagnostic bin debug which is my project
i've got here which is called request
diagnostics if i build that
and we do like that we're going to see
that in bin debug there's going to be a
request diagnostics 1.0.0.nbc
so it's a nougat package you might not
see it but it's there just trust me
um
that's why i have this little thing in
my cs profile that basically points to
that folder so that i can load when i
build this i can actually load new git
packages from my local folder that's all
it does okay
so what i want to do well the first step
in doing this is to create something
called a runtime store i need to put
stuff on my server
that an application can load without
bringing it itself so it needs to have
stuff that it didn't know about you can
use this for not stuff it's stuff that
it knows about as well so in my case
this this runtime store
it had references to bcrypt newtonsoft
and six labels image sharp as well
which happens to be the same thing that
my enterprise employee management inc
application has as well
so with that cs project file
i can go out here and this is where it
gets arcane can you guys in the
background see that
okay so i'm going to write let's see if
i i hope i have this sort of
there it is i'm going to use that code
so netstore
is saying i want to create something
called a runtime store and i want to
create it based on the runtime pro store
dot cs project file and when i run this
command it's going to create what is
called a runtime store
for those nougat packages runtime store
is a folder that contains nougat package
or sorry
it contains assemblies that generally
come out of nuget packages
i give it a run time i'm running on
windows 10 x64 i tell it where to place
the output and you add dash skip dash
optimization
so chris why do you add dash skip dash
optimization because
if you don't it doesn't work
uh
i know that that sounds really really
dumb and i have googled the heck out of
this i have googled this because i want
to know what that parameter does and
nobody so far has been able to explain
on github it just says add it because if
you don't it doesn't work
so i take that as the official
explanation just add it
you run that
it downloads the nougat packages and it
creates it and it stores a list of
packages in this address at this address
here so let's do explorer
and let's go to
c colon backslash demo backslash runtime
store like that
so sorry i can't really well i could
probably assume this but you'll just
have to trust me it says x64 in here and
in there it says net 5.0 and in there it
has one folder for each one of the
nougat packages and inside of each one
of those there is 1.1.6.0
and then inside that there's a lib
folder and inside that there's a net
standard 2.0 and inside there there's a
dll
this
whole net x64 net five blah blah blah
makes sense and it has to be like that
and the runtime store creates that and
it also creates this artifact.xml file
the artifact.xml file looks like that
and it basically says in this runtime
store that you're looking at right now
basically this folder of folders of
folders of folders of assemblies
this is what you can find
sweet what can i do with that well
what we can do now and i need to have
this because i need to remember all of
my arcane weird things
here we go back out to my application
and we go i'm just going to see if i'm
in the right place i am so what we're
going to do is we're going to say dot
net
dot dot
publish and i think i've got that look
at that no no the wrong one that one
very important so i'm going to run this
you all recognize this code i guess in
some form most of you probably don't run
it
on a console you go into visual studio
and you press f5 or you press ctrl shift
b or whatever you do but dotnet publish
release build output to demo publish and
use that folder for the project i run
that it builds my application
it builds my
application there it is
it's amazing then we open up another
powershell window
we zoom in so you guys in the back can
see it cdc colon backslash demo
als cd publish
ls there it is that's my application
and
as you can see
it has the bcrypt.net core it has the
newtonsoft.json and so on and so on and
if i run this application it's going to
run let's just
okay let's say that it actually does run
i might be wrong but if we go enterprise
there it is dll and the application runs
fine sweet
so
that's fine
don't
let's let's just do that it's fine
um
but what happens if we say cd dot dot
and we do explorer
dot and just remove that folder
we remove the publish folder
and then we go back in here and we say
we run that same thing again
but we add actually let's let's do it
like this because i had the code already
let's do f
that didn't that all work
let's do
dotnet publish
that's what i want so let's do the same
code the only difference here the same
command the only difference is i'm
adding dash dash manifest
dash manifest and then i give it the
address or the path to my artifact.xml
file
if i run this now
it builds the thing again
and if i go back to this other
powershell window and we do ls
and we go into the publish folder and we
do ls again we do that you can read it
all of those assemblies are gone now
right
so it's only my own assemblies none of
this stuff that was defined in that
artifact xml file is included in my
build at all
so once we've got that it's really cool
because then you do net and you do
enterprise dll and you run it and it
goes uh
you suck
i paraphrase it it does actually say
package not found or something like that
obviously it's not finding my package
but chris you said you had a runtime
store what happened well it you have to
tell it that there's a runtime story it
doesn't just magically know that
somewhere on your machine there's a
folder that happens to be called x64 and
underneath that well it doesn't do that
would be cool if it did and it would
also be really really slow so what we
need to do is we need to go in and give
it an environment variable that looks
like this
it's called
dot i think i've got that one as well so
we had not that one that one
so you have this environment variable
called dotnet shared store
once you add one of those pointing to a
shared store
or a runtime store
and then you go ahead and you run your
application again
it runs
because once you do dot when you run.net
and give it to dll it's going to look
for that
environment variable it's going to look
for that address that path and inside
that path is going to look for all of
your added your assemblies
so my wife calling right now is just not
a good time sorry about that
um
and then it basically goes
do you want to load stuff you can now
load it from here as well and it does a
combination of loading of what's local
to your thing and whatever folder you
have
so wait that is step number one of
touching your applications in an
inappropriate way that your colleagues
don't know about
that sounds so much worse when i say it
right it sounded much better in my head
okay so now and this is kind of cool
because we can do this for more stuff
it's not just for what i want to show
this is actually a cool step in if
you've got your own servers this is a
little bit harder to do if you go to web
application web apps in azure for
example but if you have control over
your server you can pre-load your server
with a ton of nougat packages that your
application needs so that when you build
your app you only deploy your little
piece you don't need to deploy 100 megs
of nougat packages it just goes here
this is the xml file with within the
runtime store that's going to be on the
server when you get there and then you
set up the environment variable on the
server and when you deploy there it's
going to go i've got two dlls here and i
got 600 dlls over here that was already
on the server
sounds a lot like something called the
global assembly cache
it is nothing at all like the global
assembly cache it's like feature-wise
yes it does the same thing without all
the really crappy ideas around it
the next step is to
touch my application uh in sort of plug
into it so i've created this little
project called request diagnostics
it has a really stupid diagnostics log
has an interface called i diagnostics
log has a log method and a get content
method and the implementation is really
dumb when you run log it adds it to a
list of string and when you call get
content it returns all the list of
strings so over time it's going to
basically use up all the memory on your
machine and then it's going to crash
and
that's fine because it can restart yes
because when the application dies it
writes everything to file so when it
starts up again it reads in that file
and fills up the the list again with all
the yeah
i don't work with diagnostics i'm pretty
sure they do it in a different way
somehow but
yeah
bear with me it shows my point
um and then i have a
an a middleware where here that i've
written called diagnostics middleware
and all it really does is it adds a
slash diagnostics endpoint to the
application and when you go to slash
diagnostics it shows you the log
everything in the log is being output
for you
that's all i've got
so i need to inject this into my
application and the way that we do that
is that we go ahead and say
add a new class in here
add
class
it's going to be called
diagnostics
startup
start up filter
like that and it looks like this
so and a startup filter is a class that
implements
i start a filter
and i start filter has a method called
configure and this is funky this is this
is the kind of c-sharp syntax that if
you'd shown me this 10 years ago my head
would have gone
i don't want to work with this anymore
i'm going to work with javascript um
it
yeah i know i was weird back then
um
it's a configure method that takes an
action so a callback of application
builder and returns an action of
application builder
so to be able to inject myself into the
application builder i return a method
or a callback that uses app.use
middleware to inject my requests or
request diagnostic diagnostics
middleware so an eye startup filter
any class that implements i startup
filter that you add to a asp.net core's
dependency injection
will be run
exactly
there
so basically if you put stuff into ioc
and that implements i start a filter
when you get to the configure method it
will run those startup filters before
and give you access to that app thing
here which means that my diagnostic
startup filter can go ahead and
add itself add the middleware inside of
that
step one
how do i get the sort of filter into ioc
is i guess step two
that you do by adding another class
so you go add class
and this one is supposed to be called
diagnostics
hosting startup
like that and implementation that was
spelt like i was drunk and i promise you
i am not
yet
wrong
um
it implements i hosting startup
so i hosting startup is something you
add to a class it implements a configure
method but instead of getting access to
the app builder it gets a hold of the
iweb host builder so basically it allows
me to plug in to this
which means that when the application
starts up i can inject stuff into the
isa container thus i can inject my
diagnostics log and i can inject my
startup filter
and you then have to add a hosting
startup attribute to it which is
assembly level so that the system knows
that where to find my hosting startup
thing
with that in place i can go ahead and
build this request diagnostics package
but before i can do that i have to go to
properties and i need to create a new
version of it
so i'm going to go to package i'm going
to update the version to
1.0.1 save that
i'm going to build my
request diagnostics build
like that i'm going to rebuild my
runtime store so that it updates with
with my 1.0 because in this thing it
actually says uh 1.0.star
okay so now i've got my package and
everything so the first thing i need to
do is let's see i've just done
everything i need to update that rebuild
it to generate the package
okay so we go back out here
i'm going to recreate my package store
so i'm going to go and say
that
and if we go to the folder where it was
located the runtime store we can now see
that
under the request diagnostics folder
which is there there are now two folders
one for 1.00 and one for 1.01
step one done i have my runtime store
and i have my nasty little injection
things that will go in and jump into
your application now i need it to load
it
and the problem with loading it is yes i
could probably tell it somehow to load
request diagnostics
but request diagnostics will also
potentially need other assemblies so to
load that i will actually need it to
load other assemblies into memory and
things like that and you can do that
of course i wouldn't be here otherwise
but if you go into your application if
you go to any application and you open
up
the bin folder and the debug folder and
your application which down here they
all have this thing called a
a depth.json file
the depth.json file defines what
dependencies should be loaded into
memory for this application to work
if i take the depth.json version from
runtime store and i remove the actual
runtime store from it because i don't
want to load that but i do want to load
bcrypt json request diagnostics and
image sharp and the compiler services
and i remove that like that
i can then take that this is this is
where it starts getting
ish
if i take that and we say let's see if i
remember everything we can say x copy
that so i copied the runtime stores back
actually that was hard to read let's do
it
x copy there it is so if i copy the
runtimestore.debs.json
into a folder called additional depths
and then under additional depth you have
to have a very specific folder structure
which is shared microsoft asp.net core
app which is saying that any application
on your machine
that starts with a that uses asp.net
core version
5.0.0 should also load these
dependencies
so any application that uses a smart
core app should load their
dependencies i put into my depth file so
that includes
loading
my extra request diagnostics file into
memory so it's available
okay that's a good start the next part
is a bit more complicated and we need to
go over here
so it won't just work
that's the little checkbox in in azure
as well you need to do some more so what
you need to do is you need to say dot n
and set up an environment variable call
and it should be called
that
so on your server you need to have an
environment variable called net
additional depth
that tells dot net core that when you
start an application
whatever application that starts from
this machine that sees this environment
variable we'll go to that folder
it will look into that shared folder and
see if there's a folder name based on
the same app type that you're starting
up in this moment which in my case is
going to be an html core app in version
5.0.0 and it's going to find my little
dependencies json file and it's going to
load those dependencies in so i'm
actually loading in assemblies that the
actual application hasn't asked for i'm
just loading the extra stuff that i want
on top of the application
and then you have to go and say dot and
colon and asp.net core hosting startup
assemblies because you need to tell
asp.net core
what assemblies that have to be loaded
into memory
it should look into to find hosting
startup assemblies so basically where do
you find that hosting startup thing that
starts up to inject things into the isa
once you have that in place
you run.net
enterprise dll
and if you look here it says adding
generic diagnostics to system
diagnostics available at slash
diagnostics
if i run my application i did run it if
i surf to it and i browse to localhost
and it's not that addresses it's 5000 it
it answers nice i can log in
like that and that works and if i go to
slash diagnostics i get my diagnostics
output
and if i stop this application
i'm apparently doing something wrong
oh i know what why this is not working
okay so
i i could fix that i can just show you
what i did wrong so if you don't sit
there and go he did something wrong and
he failed um i think i forgot to
implement that yes
so that should be
that sorry i just forgot to stop async
stuff to my my thumbnail generator
that's why it felt but that was not the
important part if you go back out here
we go
ls
diagnostics.log because the last thing
that happens in my my thing
is that when the application shuts down
which is also a nice thing that i
probably forgot to mention inside of the
log
i used this thing i didn't actually know
existed either which is i host
application lifetime which is an
interface that tells you when your
application is starting and when your
application is stopping so if you want
to know when your asp.net core
application is about to stop and do
something you can go ahead and you can
listen to the application stopping
event and basically say when it stops go
and write all the file to disk and that
is kind of what happened happened here
so if we go
that's my log
so i managed to inject myself into my
application without the application
knowing
by
creating a runtime store to store my
nougat packages create an additional
depth folder to have my additional
dependencies that should be loaded with
all applications created and i host
start heart hosting startup to be able
to access my ioc container to inject my
startup filter that goes ahead and
injects things into
swait
um and i did that with
less than two minutes to go
so um i want to thank you all for
listening i hope you got
something out of it
somewhere around here i did actually
have a powerpoint slide where you could
find my
contact details if you ever want to talk
to me um i have a minute or two if
anybody has any questions
oh yeah the code is available as well at
that address
so if you want to download it code and
have a look at it it's all there my blog
which i think is on that address as well
uh is is has a bunch of documentation
about how to do it it's fairly
undocumented in some parts uh so if
anybody has any questions um i'm happy
to say that take them if you want to
leave and go out and have some food or
whatever go ahead and do that thank you
all for coming don't forget if you like
the session there are green little notes
out there if you didn't like the session
just look to the right when you go out
the door and keep walking
thank you everyone
you